i think i accidentally clicked on a
three plus two challenge in
may i say unholy and wrong
form of chess because there is
none of the beauty of flagging
involved in this game it's just you make
moves and i make moves
that make the better player win who's
enjoying these things
is this theory
hammer is rating me i don't know how how
twitch works
it sounds scary do i have to defend
against the raid
what what's the policy there do i have
to say thank you to have to return
the courtesy do i have to counter rate
i'm so confused ah he stopped you
stopped your stream when i started
and sent your viewers to challenge me
wow hi hi hammer boys
i'm confused now i don't know i don't
know how to act
how are your viewers hammer are they are
they nice and friendly
because i'm awkward around new people
don't say anything mean please lawrence
trend is on the show tomorrow
save your mean jokes
i have to rate them back so next time i
should
i should start my show before hammer
starts his
and then when he starts i should say
go away i quit go watch hammer
hammer says i'll give you a lesson
twitch mechanics and terminology someday
200 an hour i don't have that kind of
money
i'm not i'm not a streamer i just have a
regular job hammer
i can't pay 200 an hour
and 314159 math says
writing is great for you it brings
people to you how is that great for me
i don't want any people around
i'm confused also
these really the time to connect people
twitch do you think about that
i'm not that funny i'm new to to twitch
maybe i have to take the hammer the
hammer course
also gmnr while i am like learning
in the basics here he's quietly
outplaying me
ravior is saying just don't insult soul
secure
or bjorn darling and you will be okay i
know who these people are
ola einer solzkier
see the guy who scored the goal for
manchester against bayern
all right time to focus on the chess
something i hear sometimes to my great
amazement
people tell me stick to the chest
and then i stick to the chest and then
they tell me
don't stick to the chest so hard
so hard to please everybody whoa rook f4
does that work
do you think that through sir
now i have to think
don't like it don't want to
can i take
let's find out
is saying what's the best way to learn
how to play chess
i believe the best and many people say
the only way
is to follow at gm
jlh on twitch
is that is that correct am i returning
the favor correctly
[Music]
we'll be here for a while i agreed for
no good reason whatsoever to play for
hours
and hours and i have nothing
remotely interesting or intelligent to
say
so if you just came here
because of the young ludwig hammer rate
and you want to check the show out i
should tell you
there are better uses of your time
tonight and probably at most stages
this is just an aging bumbling fool
trying not to blunder all his pieces
like after 95 rook f4 check
so i would encourage you to i don't know
watch
maybe the last dance and the jordan
documentary that's interesting
or what else could you possibly watch
there's not a lot of good stuff to watch
out there right i'm watching some
italian tv show
called sabura no one told me it's in
italian which i don't speak
and but it's still pretty decent
just a box in a cage is saying have been
following him for years and i know on
paso no
thanks hammer i see can i queen my pawn
i would like to queen my paw
what's going on is that beef in the
chest 24 chad
stop beefing boys
offers me a draw i don't want to draw
i want queen my pawn but then he queens
his pawn
maybe i'm not winning after all that's
bitter disappointment
yeah i'm not even better all right then
i'll have to flag but i'll feel
i'll feel dirty and filthy again
i think i have to overcome this feeling
bad about flagging i think the culture
has changed
because in the old days on the internet
chess club it was
a giant crime
to flag anybody well nowadays
look at these young guns the carlsons
the gearies
all these kids out there flagging people
left and right
without any bad conscience saying you
know what we play with the clock
if your clock goes to zero you lose the
game it's your problem
not mine and i like to think
that i contributed a little bit
to turning the culture into
dirty flaggers instead of these friendly
gunslingers from the old day
let's play an honorable game and if the
position is around
equal after both of us made
50 60 moves then let's make a draw let's
not try
to win our time against each other
because that's not the gentlemanly thing
to do
and after all chess was invented
by gentlemen the german raggy musician
so please let's not hurt each other
and gm nr1
is that an unknown son of elon musk gm
nr1
sounds a bit light and resigns thanks
for the game sir